why you
L and you
CH and you try to make a full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so it's finally here after a week and a
half of waiting which you guys have been
so patient for we're finally getting
back into The Infinity Gauntlet series
and we're picking up with issue number
five but in order to refresh you guys in
order to make make sure that you guys
recall where it was that we left off
we're going to touch back on issue
number four and what we had seen with
Issue Number Four was that the Earth
bound superheroes had engaged con uh
Thanos in conflict and as we had seen
Thanos was able to make quick work of
the Earthbound superheroes and this was
for a singular purpose it was designed
to be a diversion as Adam Warlock had
explained it to us there was no real
expectation that the Earthbound
superheroes would succeed the purpose of
them was to distract Thanos away from
Adam warlock's actual plan and the plan
that Adam Warlock had was to have the
Silver Surfer intervene at the most
opportune moment whereby he would snatch
The Gauntlet off the hand of Thanos but
as we had seen Thanos was able to keep
this from happening at the very last
second and retain The Infinity Gauntlet
for himself and so we saw Adam Morlock
bringing in the second group of forces
we saw him introducing the cosmic
entities and as we see with issue number
five as it begins to open up is that
Thanos is confronting the uh the uh
Cosmic entities and again I'd like you
to notice the amount of arrogance that
Thanos is displaying here what he's
telling the uh the cosmic entities is
that the power he possesses is beyond
anything they could understand and again
this is Thanos being very arrogant the
first reason why he's so arrogant here
the reason why it seems that he's so uh
so confident is because he possesses all
this power but the other reason here is
because he does not necessarily have the
same wisdom that a lot of these Cosmic
entities have because they they've been
in existence since the dawn of existence
in this reality because they're manifest
ations various repres representations of
reality for example eternity being the
very representation of the essence of
everything within the cosmos the uh
ongoings of reality itself of course has
existed since the dawn of reality so
we've seen countless civilizations and
countless organisms come into existence
and then die and so for Thanos to appear
and to say he knows more than they do is
uh quite an arrogant thing to say what
we also see is that Mesto is being a
little U manipul ative here and again
we'll see later on that Mesto has his
own mechan naations in terms of his
involvement with Thanos but we see that
Mesto is more less poking fun at OS he's
talking to OS about how Thanos with his
absolute power is most likely going to
unleash it in its full force in order to
either demonstrate his power to the
cosmic entities or it's going to be
necessary for him to defeat the cosmic
entities but because such a vast amount
of power is going to be released in such
a way that most likely it will result in
the destruction of Heroes now he says
that because Thanos can manipulate the
very fabric of reality most likely he
will destroy anything he cares about I'm
sorry a restore anything he cares about
that had been destroyed and that this
may very well in include OS but he says
that if OS is brought back that most
likely he will be brought back in the
same form as nebula more or less a husk
of what used to be a a sentient being
and so for OS this is horrifying OS is
absolutely distraught at the idea of
coming back and kind of walking this
line between life and death not
necessarily being considered alive but
not being allowed to die and so what we
see as the conflict begins to unfold as
things begin to progress is that Thanos
unleashes this power that he has and the
way it's done here it seems to be just
absolute power absolute raw ability and
The Watcher explains to us in telling us
that this is the initial Clash this is
the initial conflict that the cosmic
entities have with Thanos and what we'll
see as the story progresses is that the
cosmic entities will each take turns
trying to defeat Thanos using the powers
that are relevant to them and what the
Watcher tells us here is that he's
afraid that this may very well uh Herald
the end of the universe this may bring
everything to an end just because of the
sheer amount of power that's going to be
displayed but as we see as things begin
to uh take their toll as the damage
begins to become apparent that the
entire Shrine that Thanos had made
towards mistress death had been
destroyed as well as according to the
Watcher various solar systems and and
galaxies within uh the direct I guess
the immediate um area of where Thanos is
unleashing his power from we then at
this point switched to OS and Os was
absolutely certain that he was going to
be killed he was absolutely sure he was
going to die but what was very
surprising to OS was not only the fact
that he was very much alive but the fact
that he was being saved or being kept
Alive by mistress death herself
alongside nebula and so what ero
speculates here is that the hatred that
mistress death has for Thanos is quite
possibly something none of them can
understand just because she's going to
the lengths of saving the individuals
wish Thanos toest the most and so again
this may simply just be an instance of
her saying that she absolutely despises
Thanos at this point we switched to uh
Adam Warlock and the Silver Surfer and
Adam Warlock comments that it's absolute
luck that they survived that for
whatever reason they somehow made it out
of here but almost immediately after the
uh the initial explosion and they're
sort of calming down due to the fact
that they've managed to survive this
there's some kind of strange thing
emanating around them and what Adam
Warlock tells the Silver Surfer is that
this is an interdimensional Distortion
Cascade now what this means exactly is
not something that's explained to us
this moment but what we see as the story
continues is that Adam Warlock says that
they need to get out of here as soon as
they can because if they get sucked into
it they may not survive they may be sent
to another dimension they may be
eradicated entirely in addition this uh
interdimensional Distortion Cascade is
explained to us further once it reaches
the planet Earth and what this seems to
be is uh perhaps a weakening or a uh a I
maybe a dissolving of the barriers
between Dimensions between realities and
this seems to become apparent for a
couple reasons the first is that at this
point again the Earth has been moved or
has been sort of bumped out of its orbit
from the Sun and so the Earth is
becoming colder and colder but we see
that the portal between the Negative
Zone where anilist resides and the
planet Earth seems to have at the very
least been weakened or maybe torn apart
entirely and so anilus is able to enter
the uh the dimension of the earth 616
Universe on the planet Earth from the
Negative Zone from here we see anilist
continuing to implement his schemes with
a cosmic control rod and his forces
saying that they are for the most part
going to conquer the planet Earth at
this point we switch back to Thanos and
what we see Thanos doing is using his
Infinity Gauntlet to demonstrate his
absolute power to demonstrate his
ability and as The Watcher describes it
to us this is something to behold that
the heavens themselves tremble now again
the important thing to keep in mind here
is that despite the fact that Thanos is
able to wield all of this power that it
is confined to the Earth 616 universe
that Thanos is not affecting any other
universes that may exist or that do
exist around him what we also see is
that the celestials are the first ones
to step into the conf towards Thanos and
the celestials use various planets as a
means to attempt to topple Thanos or
attempt to somehow destroy him or
incapacitate him and The Watcher says
that these planets are inhabited
although it may very well be that at
this point because they're so far
removed from the warmth of the Sun that
most likely would have kept the
inhabitants alive that they may very
well be dead that it's not relevant that
the goings on of these uh these
organisms these Celestial beings cannot
be a consideration in this conflict that
they have to more or less be sacrificed
in order for the greater good to uh to
come out but we see that again Thanos is
able to use the power of The Infinity
Gauntlet to easily not only uh destroy
these uh these planets the forces that
the celestials are trying to use to
defeat Thanos but to defeat the
celestials entirely now it's important
to remember Thanos isn't actually
killing the celestials he's more or less
simply just sort of defeating them here
the next group up is or I guess the next
individual up is Kronos and and again
Kronos is able to manipulate the very
fabric of time and this is what he
attempts to do with Thanos he attempts
to maybe somehow bury Thanos within the
depths of time as the Watcher explains
it to us or to maybe send him to a place
in time where he doesn't know where he
is or doesn't know how to get back but
again because Thanos is able to
manipulate all facets of time he
immediately travels back to the present
and he more or less uh is able to defeat
uh Kronos he's more or less able to do
whatever it is that he has to do in
order to incapacitate Kronos at this
point we jump to master order and Lord
Chaos and what we see Master order and
Lord Chaos doing here is using the
respective Powers using the respective
dichotomies I guess in an attempt to
sort of dichotomize Thanos in an attempt
to I guess maybe strip away the uh order
that makes him who he is the very
fundamental fabric of his uh existence
by separating the element of him that is
I guess orderly and the element of him
that is absolutely chaotic now what
would actually happen in this whether or
not he would simply just split into two
separate beings or he would more or less
be a representation of what would happen
if matter met antimatter and he would
simply just cease to exist is something
that we don't know because what we see
is that Thanos is very easily able to
defeat Master order in Lord Chaos he's
able to as the Watcher explains it
retain his own individuality he's able
to maintain what it is that makes him a
complete being from here we switch to
the stranger to uh to um galatis and to
the uh the representation I guess of the
new form of eon and what we see here is
that these individuals attempt to use
their absolute power they attempt to use
all the uh Power that's available to
them in an attempt to more or less
override or to overthrow the power of
Thanos to simply just um I guess
Encompass him with so much power that
there really isn't anything he can do to
stop them but again we see Thanos simply
just using the power of The Infinity
Gauntlet to easily defeat them and what
you're seeing here is this kind of
pattern you're seeing that Thanos is
able to more or less just use the
Infinity Gauntlet to Simply wipe away
everything that everybody is to simply
just uh eliminate them almost entirely
now again he's not killing them he's
simply just incapacitating them or
demonstrating to them there's nothing
they can really do at this point we
switched to Thanos sort of having this
debate between himself he's arguing with
himself here he's saying that on one
side that somehow he may have lost his
mind here that these individuals are his
friends they're his Heavenly Brothers as
he describes them but on the other side
he's arguing with himself he's saying
that they deserve what's taking place
here they deserve the punishment that
he's giving them and that he's going to
kill them all but then we see that
Thanos begins to realize what it is
that's taking place he realizes that
this is not necessarily an actual
argument that he's having with himself
that uh his emotions his perspectives
are being manipulated and that these
perspectives are being manipulated by
mistress love and sire hate and again
these are the opposing forces of love
and hate within the universe and Thanos
is able to banish them he's able to uh
uh defeat them in the same way that he
was able to defeat the other Cosmic
entities but then we see that Mesto
makes his mechan known Mesto surrounds
Thanos with hell's fire and when he does
he leaps at Thanos and attempts to
remove his Infinity Gauntlet and Thanos
is actually a little surprised by this
he's a little shocked to see that Mesto
is attempting to manipulate him now
whether or not this is because Thanos uh
is simply just never really taken the
time to read the mind of Mesto or
because misto is somehow able to Shield
his mind from Thanos is something that
we don't know but given the fact that
Thanos has the Mind Gem and has absolute
power over the minds of others were most
likely led to believe that Thanos had
simply just not questioned the uh the
allegiance of Mesto and again this is
most likely pointing to the arrogance
that Thanos had that anyone who's going
to side with him sides with him because
they realize how powerfully that he is
and it would be foolish for them to do
anything otherwise from here we see the
Thanos is again able to easily overpower
misto and it's in the process where I
guess is preparing to kill Mesto for his
actions but before he can actually kill
Mesto we see that the two of them are
separated by the actions of a third
party and what we see is that mistress
death has intervened on behalf of Mesto
and saved his life by more or less
putting uh pushing Thanos out of the way
and Thanos feels betrayed here he feels
angry here because for him this is the
ultimate step that mistress death has
taken to demonstrate that not only has
he not gained her affections but that
there's nothing he can really do here in
this circumstance as it appears to
please her Thanos says that he offered
her the universe that he did everything
he could to make her happy but she
simply just couldn't accept it at this
point we see the cosmic entities using
their power alongside Mesto and mistress
death to um I guess intervene while he's
distracted and to blast them with or
blast them with the I guess all of their
combined Powers but again Thanos
recognizes what it is that's taking
place here and immediately overpowers
all of them and when he does he
imprisons them he uh places them in some
kind of a cosmic stasis now most likely
as is displayed here at least as we can
see they may simply just uh be
temporarily I guess paralyzed or
temporarily imprisoned but they're not
making any effort to escape their bonds
they're not making any effort to escape
their struggle and so it seems as though
that for the most part he's imprisoned
and Frozen them so whether or not they
actually know what's going on here is
something that we don't really know
anything about we're simply just aware
that they're frozen in place and so what
Thanos says is that this is the best way
for things to function at the moment
that he simply just needs time to f
Focus he needs time to be unburdened
with the emotions of uh his feelings of
betrayal by mistress death and to Simply
uh take the time and the logic to decide
what his next step will be at this point
we see that Adam Warlock and the Silver
Surfer don't necessarily go as far as to
say that all time or I guess all hope
may be lost but they're actually going
through the process of trying to find
survivors because again some of these
superheroes are still left alive and so
what they say is that among the wreckage
they need to find help but among the
planets that have been destroyed here
are some or I guess at least one planet
that the Silver Surfer recognizes and
the Silver Surfer says that he'd visited
this planet before whether or not it was
something he had done on behalf of
Thanos or something he was just curious
about seeing isn't explained to us but
he says they have to search for these
individuals they have to search for
these uh these survivors among the
wreckage Adam Warlock initially advises
against it but uh the Silver Surfer says
that this is an instance where whereby
he is not going to heed the advice of
Adam Warlock that the the desire to uh
protect those that are unable to save
themselves as a result of the conflict
overrides the fact that uh they need to
sort of reather forces here but what we
see as Adam Warlock and the Silver
Surfer approach this planet is that
there is no one left that all these
individuals are dead all these uh these
beings that existed on this planet are
completely ended or I guess completely
uh destroyed from here we see that the
Silver Surfer actually takes this quite
hard the Silver Surfer as is explained
by Adam Warlock is an individual despite
his vast powers that functions in the
same capacity for the most part as other
sentient beings in that he feels love he
feels hate he feels remorse and this is
a very overwhelming experience for the
Silver Surfer to know that the entire
inhabitants of this planet have been
destroyed in the midst of all this chaos
and so the Silver Surfer says this needs
to end Adam Warlock agrees here Adam
Warlock says that Thanos is a anilist
and that in order for this uh conflict
to come to an end that he has to be
defeated entirely otherwise he will
eliminate all life in the universe not
necessarily because he's looking to
appease mistress death anymore but
because he is in effect a heartbroken
being and will lash out at virtually
everybody from this point we see that uh
eternity has now joined the fry and
Eternity is as we know the most powerful
of the cosmic entities and so this
conflict between Thanos and ET it will
for the most part tell us exactly who it
is that is more powerful here whether or
not it's Thanos using his Infinity
Gauntlet or eternity using the vast
power of the very fabric of the earth
616 Universe uh within itself as a means
to combat Thanos what we see Thanos
saying here is that the prize that
awaits him with defeating eternity is
something he has struggled for the
absolute authority of power within the
universe is something he has strived for
and this as he explains to us is the
actual result of his plan this is really
what he was looking for when he went
about the process of capturing the
infinity gems and what we see is that
eternity simply tells Thanos to to
prepare himself to defend himself but
before we actually see what takes place
between the two of them there's some
kind of an explosion or some kind of
conflict and all we see is a as a bright
light with Adam Warlock and Silver
Surfer saying that this that this can't
be the end this can't be the end of the
universe but this conflict has to
somehow come to an end in entirely from
here we see the Silver Surfer and Adam
Warlock more or less surprised by what
it is that's going on and Adam Warlock
says that the end of this battle has
more or less already been decided Adam
Warlock I'm sorry Silver Surfer asks how
it is that Adam Warlock knows this and
Adam Warlock says that he's linked to
the infinity gems in ways that even he
doesn't understand and so the question
that's asked here by the Silver Surfer
is who's come out on top here is it
eternity or is it Thanos with The
Infinity Gauntlet what he says is that
the person who loses is the person who
has chosen to feed subconsciously who
has already simply just allowed himself
to lose and so what we see Adam Warlock
more or less saying is that the
successor here is most likely Thanos and
the reason why is because eternity
recognized the fact that Thanos probably
has more power than he does but that
eternity is not fighting logically he's
not fighting reasonably he's fighting
out of anger he's fighting out of Rage
he's owing his emotions to get the
better of him and when a person fights
in an emotional state they're not
thinking rationally and by virtue they
can't be intelligent at this point we
see Adam Warlock telling uh doctor
strange that they need to be retrieved
and so Doctor Strange teleports them
back to the planet Earth what we see uh
again kind of going on here is this
explanation of what all has taken place
that the cosmic entities have been imp
imprisoned but then we get I guess a
little further expansion by saying here
that CA I guess that eternity is one of
the cosmic entities that has now been
imprisoned indicating to us that Thanos
has in fact come out on top that Thanos
has been able to use his power to defeat
eternity and so from here we see that
for the most part Thanos doesn't
necessarily appear to be dead he simply
appears to be unconscious and terraxia
is trying to speak with him she's trying
to awaken him from her from his State
and she she asks him to simply just
speak to say something to do something
to indicate that he's alive but what we
see is that Thanos appears in the I
guess the the cosmic entity form of
Eternity indicating to us that Thanos
has usurped eternity as the absolute
Authority within the Marvel Earth 616
Universe from here we're going to bring
the first part of video number five
where I guess of Infinity Gauntlet
number five to an end and we'll pick up
in the next video when we see this sort
of panic taking place and we see that
the defeat of Thanos comes from what we
would consider to be the most unlikely
person the one person that none of us
had really considered to be a threat at
this particular point in time with that
being said I'm going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later
[Music]
[Laughter]
peace
[Music]
sh